[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on discute
échanges sur des thèmes d'actualité
alors des restaurants et théâtres et
cinémas fermés depuis le 20 octobre 2020
des commerces clos depuis le 20 mars
dernier plusieurs mois sans voir clients
et spectateurs jusqu'à ce mercredi 19
mai où les rideaux ont pu être relevées
mais les clients sont ils de retour on
en parle avec nos invités gaëtan malon
dans un bon soir bonsoir
vous êtes propriétaire de l'atelier de
gaëtan une crêperie à juziers jean
daniel laval bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directeur du théâtre cinéma de fontenay
le fleury et karine michy bonsoir en
soit vous êtes responsable de tout autre
chose une boutique de décoration à
versailles alors vous êtes parmi les
secteurs les plus touchés un style
difficile de donner une échelle de
valeur il y en a qui ont été
particulièrement touchées sont les
restaurants gaëtan malanda le 19 mai
vous avez choisi de faire une journée
spéciale est très très long puisque dès
6h30 vous proposiez des petits déjeuners
est ce que les clients ont répondu
présent oui tous les clients étaient là
dès la première heure ça s'est très bien
passé et ça nous a fait un grand bien de
voir tous nos clients
c'était des habitués vous avez vu aussi
des nouveaux des curieux non c'était pas
du tout c'était des gens qu'on ne
connaissait pas spécialement est
d'autant plus de bien et ça s'est super
bien passé des rentes
il y avait les premiers clients qui est
qui est présent pour leur petit déjeuner
et vous à karine michelez comment s'est
passé alors la reprise de votre commerce
ça s'est très bien passé nous on a eu la
rue d'anjou qui a revécu tous les des
restaurants ont mis leurs terrasses tous
les commerçants ouverts on était tous
déjà très contents de se revoir
et puis les les gens étaient au rendez
vous aussi
il avait hâte de pouvoir venir de venir
nous saluer un à même certains qui nous
ont offert des boîtes de chocolat
ils étaient très contents de nous voir
donc ça c'est pas trop mal passé
voilà jean daniel laval les théâtres et
cinémas ont aussi pu rouvrir le 19 mai
dernier et certains ont fait le choix de
garder les rideaux fermés d'attendre la
rentrée de la saison prochaine quel a
été le choix fontenay le fleury de la
partie théâtre alors pour la partie
théâtre il a le choix était assez
naturel parce qu'il faut savoir que pour
les théâtreux de ce qu'on appellerait
les tables de ville il faut savoir que
la période de mai juin général elle est
souvent consacrée aux interventions
prestation je dirais scolaire les
collèges les lycées qui font leur
spectacle de fin d'année
donc on n'est pas vraiment sur une
programmation traditionnelle avec des
spectacles invités ou de spectacles
achetés et nous on est dans ce contexte
là donc on ouvre évidemment nos portes à
ces spectacles qui sont importants parce
que ça représente parfois 600 700
spectateurs qui tourne selon les écoles
du spectacle ayant 140 élèves
donc on va faire ça on a le collège
descartes puisqu'on est affronté
l'euphorie donc qu'il va faire une
prestation aussi musical on a le collège
de villepreux qui est à côté qui va
venir aussi
donc on est ouverts je dirai au sens où
on accueille du public n'est pas ouvert
celui de saison traditionnelle en
revanche le cinéma nous nous avons
attendu le 2 juin
parce que bien des gens le savent pas
forcément mais quand on dit à la
télévision sur des chaînes concurrentes
à la vôtre que tout se passe bien qu'il
ya 400 films qui sont en attente
il parle que des gros majeur et de
l'industrie du cinéma parce
qu'évidemment c'est des sujets c'est les
pâtes et les gourmands qui se gardent
les bébés puisque nous ils nous les
reverse trois semaines ou quatre
semaines en repart donc si ça ouvre le
19 on les aura donc quatre semaines
c'est-à-dire le 19 juin le 15 juin
c'est sûr donc on peut pas vraiment
ouvrir alors on pouvait ouvrir avec des
films anciens qui étaient déjà sorties
sauf que nous on les avait déjà un passé
c'est à dire adieu les cons à des fins
gros succès en première partie est juste
avant le confinant donc c'était un peu
dommage de faire des plats réchauffés
donc on a fait ce choix en fait vous
savez je vous raconte une petite
anecdote c'est que
donc l'an dernier sur le premier
déconfinement on avait fait le choix
pareil
malgré la pression municipale et la
pression des environs de l'environnement
de d'ouvrir avec deux semaines de retard
et bien nous en a pris parce que les
cinémas d'à côté se sont retrouvées à
sec avec plus de films puisqu'ils
avaient tous versé et du coup on est
obligé de fermer deux semaines après et
je vais vous dire aussi autre chose
c'est que cette ouverture je dis pas ça
pour mes camarades de commerçants des
restaurants et tout ça c'est que ça a
été sans doute après dans la suite des
choses la pire période de vacances qu'on
ait eu donc je veux dire qu'il faut être
très très vigilant sur ce retour excité
enthousiaste des gens qui vont venir sur
les premiers jours il faut être très
prudent sur la suite c'est à dire
vraiment faire un vrai travail d'accueil
au sens où retrouver bien ses marques et
ne pas être dans l'ain en espèce
d'euphorie ça c'est mon avis après
évidemment certains cachent que moi donc
justement ses clients parce qu'on en
parle ses clients ses spectateurs
on a été à leur rencontre nicolas
d'andré mie câline nous devrons nous
fait un petit peu de lèche vitrine à
versailles pour ressent recueillir les
sentiments des clients très bien je suis
très contente que ça est réouvert et en
effet je vais faire mes courses en
magasin de préférence et d'autant que ça
fait très peu de temps que j'habite
versailles et du coup je m'étais
installé tout était encore fermé là je
découvre avec joie tous les commerces de
la ville
ah bah ça fait du bien je ne vous le
cache pas on commence un petit peu à
retrouver un semblant de vie normale
même si c'est un début d'accord
on espère que ça va continuer dans ce
sens là je trouve qu'ils sont essentiels
déjà c'est indispensable
et ben je suis très contente voilà c'est
une bouffée d'air frais surtout qu'on
vit dans ma enfin normalement
c'est à dire que les lacets jusqu'à
quelle heure 21h enfin c'est comme si
on n'était plus du tout habitués je suis
hyper contente c'est merveilleux et
la ville est beaucoup plus gai
ça met une ambiance
n'ont servi on reprend reprend vie au
sens que lui quand on a les terres à
ceux qui sont occupées maintenant oui on
va dans le bons du bon côté qu'étant
malanda cette joie aussi vous continuez
à la vive depuis une semaine c'était
l'excitation du 19 mai alors non non non
non il ya toujours du monde même si pour
le moment nous n'avons pas la chance
quand même par la météo
on essaye de faire au mieux mais bon
c'est un peu compliqué par la météo mais
tous les clients sont quand même là ils
sont quand même présents ils sont très
très content même sous la pluie
ils sont quand même présents et quart et
demi ce livre vous l'avez est-ce que
vous aussi vous avez dû proposer
d'autres choses aux clients pour les
faire revenir où vous avez voulu faire
comme la vie d'avant non j'ai fait des
superbe vitrine enfin j'essayais juste
de faire le mon possible pour leur
donner envie de venir une vitrine d'été
avec des objets en naturel des choses
comme ça et puis et puis bah ils sont
revenus un petit peu et puis il ya eu
effectivement une excitation et puis là
ça retombe un petit peu l'avant il ya eu
les week-ends il ya eu voilà pilotant je
pense que ça donne pas vraiment envie de
sortir de fait froid il pleut
voilà mais je pense que ça va repartir
au mois de juin ça va repartir
oui forcément j'avais fait des mails à
ce week-end aussi peu de la fête des
mères de ce week-end peut-être un coup
de chaud c'est bon c'est ça bouge pas
beaucoup pour la fête des mères c'est
j'ai pas beaucoup de monde moi pour ça
jean daniel laval
est-ce que vous avez aussi des
spectateurs qui disent pourquoi on peut
pas retourner au cinéma maintenant
est-ce que vous vous sentez un
empressement où c'est un chemin qui a
pas été fait encore non je dirais pas
que c'est un empressement je dirais que
c'est le mouvement naturel d'une
communication générale ou d'
enthousiasme collectif et qu'on
réfléchit pas on se dit oui on a été
malheureux fois de joyeux mais c'est un
peu comme le consumérisme on se jette
sur quelque chose sur un gâteau dont on
n'a pas forcément
besoin sur le long terme on a besoin
dans l'évident si immédiatement donc les
gens qui nous disent ah on leur dit avec
beaucoup de tendresse et de gentillesse
mais aller à l'ugc du coin ça marche
très bien vous inquiétez pas pas de
souci il n'y a pas de concurrence ont
fait pas les mêmes programmation on
travaille pas dans les mêmes directions
donc allez-y au contraire faites vous
plaisir
si on pouvait même subventionné leur
place on le ferait à ce que on veut pas
changer leurs méthodes si vous voulez
les gens qui allaient pas au théâtre
avant c'est pas parce qu'elle co vite
qu'ils iront au théâtre après et donc ça
c'est ça c'est une hérésie de penser ça
en revanche la bienveillance que nous
avions avant pour le client qui venait
il faut la préserver pour les clients
après donc il faut pas changer notre
comportement notre attitude à mon avis
c'est mon expérience personnelle
on a on a une capri dans le théâtre ont
fait concurrence à gaëtan j'en suis
désolé on a une crêperie dans le théâtre
et le le gérant de cet esprit il a été
très très bienveillant il a travaillé
vraiment sur la longueur dans le conte
appel l'emporter et la livraison ils ont
vraiment bien travaillé quand les gens
sont venus ils ont couvert leur terrasse
alors ils l'ont complètement couvertes
et quand les gens sont revenus ils sont
pas allés dans l'excitation ils sont
restés gens n'ont pas changé leurs prix
ils ont essayé de rénover des choses pas
pour la carte maison
voyez ce que je veux bien c'est que ils
ont fait comme si le coc vide n'était
pas forcément un drame mais un passage
qui la famille vivre collectivement je
crois que c'était intéressant comme
démarche étant mal honda vous êtes
vous-même restaurateur est ce que c'est
une démarche que vous avez gardez vous
avez fait du click and collect vous
partager ce sentiment
complètement oui pareil on a fait plein
de la vente à emporter on a fait de la
livraison
on a essayé de faire au mieux tout ce
qu'on pouvait faire pour pour s'en
sortir et pour pouvoir être
combien 2go encore mais voilà maintenant
il va falloir se relancer pour pouvoir
continuer à vivre et et voilà alors la
vie reprend on revit à ça vous voulez
rire monsieur lavage aux intrigues
pardonnez moi je vais pas prendre au
troll mais je poserai volonté la
question haggaï temps et karim comment
ils ont vécu on aime quand même deux
chocs terribles on a eu 19 décembre si
vous vous souvenez vous il ya eu des
promesses énorme et ça nous est tombé
dessus comme une grosse masse était
d'une grande violence
moi je me souviens que mes cartons de
l'impression des des promotions les
vingt cartons qui sont arrivés sont
arrivés on les a jetés à la belle dans
l'heure qui a suivi parce que l'on fermé
ce jour là et puis il ya eu la deuxième
le deuxième la réouverture et puis
refermeture je veux dire que je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui il faut il faut jouer une
espèce de prudence joyeuse si je puis me
permettre
vous restez jouer ce sont deux chaque
particulier c'est finalement les
boutiques vous avez pu rouvrir au
notamment au niveau des sols
madame micheline ça a été difficile de
relancer encore à nouveau le 19 mai
c'était une troisième relance oui parce
que c'était c'est quand même épuisants
mois je sais que la veille du
confinement j'ai reçu deux palettes
entières
parce que je m'étais dit que ça allait
repartir que voilà j'étais optimiste me
disais bon et quand je les ai vus
arriver et que le soir même on me disait
ben lendemain il faut fermer
déjà bon gdc la boutique c'est un joyeux
bordel y en avait partout il ya carton
et puis petit à petit j'ai rangé j'ai
mis des photos sur facebook sur
instagram mes clients ont commencé à
m'appeler en me disant ben voilà on
vient j'ai fait du click and collect on
s'est débrouillé on a je m'obligeais à
venir tous les matins la boutique pour
voilà pour la pour continuer parce que
rester à la maison
c'était pas possible et puis petit à
petit on reprend et puis on retravaille
et voilà il faut garder l'optimiste mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident parce
qu'on se retrouve avec des stocks
importants et bon moi j'ai la chance en
déco c'est pas trop périssables et puis
il ya des modes mais bon ça reste quand
même je sais pas comme l'habillement par
exemple
donc bon j'espère qu'avec les soldes
tout partira et que ben en septembre je
pourrai de nouveau faire de beaux achats
et renouveler tout ce que j'ai dans la
boutique voilà mais bon on verra bien
mais il faut rester optimiste mais pia
espérez que les gens vont venir et que
bah ils vous continuez à revenir dans
les petits commerces parce que je pense
que effectivement certaines personnes
ont pris conscience aussi d'importance
maintenant des des petits commerces dans
les villes et des rapports humains parce
que de plus en plus il y en a de moins
en moins de rapports humains
donc je pense que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui reviennent aux petits commerces qui
moi je vois dans ma profession qu'ils
regardent sur internet et après ils
reviennent dans les petits commerces
pour acheter justement dans le petit
commerce des choses qu'ils ont pu voir
sur internet
donc ça je trouve que c'est c'est bien
des gens commencent à avoir des
réactions un peu normal plutôt que de
venir dans les petites boutiques pour
après acheté sur internet il ya
maintenant certaines personnes qui font
à cause du confinement qui font le
contraire et je pense que c'est plutôt
très très bien monsieur malouda je vous
ai vu à clessé notamment sur le retour
au petit commerce c'est un sentiment que
vous avez aussi dans votre établissement
oui bah après comment dire pour le
moment nous tous les clients sont là
pendant la période ils ont été là sur
l'emporté sur la livraison donc pour le
moment on n'a pas trop à se plaindre et
j'espère que ça va continuer comme ça en
tout cas j'espère alors malgré tout
devient repris mais le virus il est
toujours là je vous propose qu'on écoute
marine cinelli elle est directrice
départemental yves de la rs ile de
france pour les yvelines elle nous fait
un petit point sur la situation
épidémique
la tendance va beaucoup mieux les
indicateurs l'épidémiologie qu baisse
donc moi que d'avoir eu des mesures
barrières et des mesures de contrainte
assez fortes ont permis l'évolution
favorable de l'épidémie ceci étant le
virus circule toujours
et donc il est important de pouvoir
continuer à maintenir les gestes
barrières qu'on connaît bien se laver
régulièrement
en les mains porter évidemment le masque
surtout en intérieur et puis et puis
veillez toujours à à tenir des distances
même si on est vacciné effectivement il
faut continuer a maintenant des gestes
barrières on sait que le vaccin baisse
là la propagation du virus et donc la
contagiosité ceci étant c'est pas
complètement fiable à 100% donc si on
veut passer un été sans masque est
embêté dans des conditions qui nous
permettent tous de retrouver une musique
un peu comme avant il faut qu'on soit
vraiment sérieux et que et qu'on
continue à capter ces gestes-là
justement ces gestes barrières karine
micheli à tout autre chose
c'est compliqué par la taille de votre
boutique les clientes les clients
comprennent alors les clients
comprennent pas toujours là j'ai dû
demander à deux personnes de ressortir
parce qu'il n'avait pas de masque donc
moi je mets deux personnes pas plus dans
ma boutique mais bon c'est ça j'ai du
gel à l'entrée je fais attention je
garde mes distances j'ai toujours mon
masque voilà bien le choix vacciner
voilà il faut vivre avec et puis on
espère que ça va ça va s'arrêter vite
fait et que l'on va pouvoir redevenir
normal parce que travailler toute la
journée avec un masque sur le visage
c'est pas très facile et voilà c'est
pénible surtout gaëtan malanda les
restaurants ne peuvent pas encore
accueillir des clients à l'intérieur
vous avez une terrasse une règle à sup
table de 6 personnes maximum jauge de 50
% sauf pour les petites terrasses votre
sentiment
alors moi moi j'étais toute petite
terrasse donc j'ai jeu je n'ai que vingt
places sur ma petite terrasse et donc
les les règles sont bien respectées et
voilà on a essayé de faire au mieux mais
c'est un soulagement j'imagine quand
même de pouvoir accueillir même si le
temps est pas la fête pendant basse et
toujours
mieux que rien c'est toujours mieux et
c'est surtout le plaisir c'est un vrai
plaisir de pouvoir voir voir les les
clients chez soi ça nous fait plaisir
jean daniel laval le 2 juin contre
cinéma ouvrira il y aura quand même une
règle c'est 35% de l'accueil de la salle
est ce que c'est un frein pour vous
aussi ça va pas du tout alors d'abord
nous ce qu'on avait fait ces comprimés
confinement on avait éradiqué deux
fauteuils sur veux c'est qu'on les avait
carrément enlevé et on a mis les petites
tablettes à la place un peu comme un
cabaret donc déjà au niveau du climat et
de l'ambiance
les gens adorent en fait ils trouvent
que ils peuvent poser leur sac qui
posent leur téléphone parce que avant le
premier déconfinement on pouvait manger
donc on avait autorisé les gens avec une
box à rentrer dans la salle et à manger
maintenant ils ont pas droit parce
qu'ils doivent garder leur masque
complètement mais on a quand même une
salle de 350 places dont 35% n'est pas
loin des 100 120 et au cinéma on fait
rarement plus de 120 sur une séance plus
qu'on a quand même plusieurs séances
donc franchement non au contraire on se
réjouit on est ravis d'ouvrir on a
toutes les conditions sanitaires
préserver vous savez on ne préserve pas
que pour pour faire joli ou pour
respecter les règles les préserve parce
que la clientèle est là elle a besoin
aussi d'être en sécurité
elle va se sentir en sécurité je pense
que pour gaëtan ou pour karine s'ils
font n'importe quoi dans leur restaurant
ou dans leurs magasins déjà il vraiment
pas ils diront c'est pas sérieux
non je pense donc que c'est pas que pour
bing même sinon on ne fait pas ce qu'on
règle pour tout le monde pour tous mais
finalement ce sentiment de sécurité on
parle beaucoup des clients mais vous
même les professionnels est ce que vous
avez ressenti au moment de cette
ouverture le 19 mai peut-être une
inquiétude on vous parlait de clients de
madame leslie qui ne rentrent sans
masquer ce que vous avez cette
inquiétude aussi vous parfois peut-être
de vous mettre en danger en rouvrant moi
je l'est plus maintenant parce que j'ai
eu au vide et je suis vacciné donc voila
moi je suis tranquille maintenant
et puis c'est effectivement chaque fois
que quelqu'un sort souvent je vais me
laver les mains je fais très attention
donc je suis assez assez confiante
maintenant je suis assez optimiste et je
me dis que toute façon on va s'en sortir
il faut faire confiance aussi aux gens
et je pense que les gens maintenant sont
quand même à part certains responsables
voilà quand on vous dit que je mets pas
de masse parce que dieu me protège voilà
c'est cette sonde et certaines personnes
mais heureusement il y en a une sur sur
100 comme ça ils aient eu à la boutique
mais bon c'est pas grave
et vous monsieur mal honda est ce que il
ya eu chez vous dans votre équipe
peut-être un petit sentiment
d'inquiétude à rouvrir je ne pense pas
je ne pense pas tout est mis pour
pouvoir bien tout respecter les gestes
barrière le gel les masques
donc je pense pas qu'il y ait d'un
d'inquiétude pour le moment personne n'a
parlé dans le dans le sable isme en tout
cas jean daniel laval certains autres
cinémas nous confie que dans les six
prochains mois on pourrait manquer de
films nouveau à projeter
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète dont vous
vous avez connaissance aussi non ça
m'inquiète pas mais je suis désolé vous
savez j'ai une nature pas du tout
inquiète donc j'ai un très mauvais
souvenir pour vous mais n'annonce avec
en plus un signe en moins de films
vous savez le répertoire il est grand on
peut retrouver des bus de ville qui sont
magnifiques on peut retrouver
on avait en avait eu l'idée de repasser
vous savez tous ces films on regarde sur
les petits écrans et qui ne se regardent
que ceux des grands écrans comédie était
une fois dans l'ouest où comme ou comme
ben-hur voyez on a plein de projets et
nos possibilités et les gens n'aiment
pas le cinéma que parce que c'est des
films récents qui sortent disait parce
qu'ils aiment la venturi l'onirisme nous
allons entrer dans des grandes histoires
je pense et puis quand au sérieux dont
on parlait tout à l'heure une petite
anecdote pour peut-être faire sourire on
a eu beaucoup de compagnies qui sont
venus répéter puisque on n'y était
autorisé donc notre théâtre reste ouvert
tout le temps est très en activité et
alors les compagnies dès qu'elle faisait
ce qu'on appelle un filage desquels
décidé de travailler avec le masque
était qu elle décidé de faire un filage
sans masque parce qu'évidemment c'était
quand même plus agréable
alors ils passaient tous le matins faire
leur test pcr il arrivait tous avec
leurs petits un peu d'aidé s'agit des
mais on peut jouer ensemble pensé bon
c'est rigolo non non ils ont beaucoup
respecté et très sérieux j'étais même
impressionné parce que je crois que le
pire c'est de sa bête noire dans
l'histoire
allez je vous rassure ce n'est pas que
pour parler d'inquiétude mais il ya
aussi l'été qui arrive on sait que
souvent les parisiens la grande couronne
quittent l'île de france il y aurait
peut-être moins de touristes
est ce que c'est une échéance qui vous
inquiète tous les trois dans votre
secteur d'activité où finalement les
franciliens vont être resté en ile de
france
madame micheline et peut-être pour
commencer moi j'ai moi je suis pas très
inquiète parce que enfin j'ai pas j'ai
pas énormément de touristes qui viennent
dans ma boutique
j'ai surtout une clientèle versaillaise
des alentours et beaucoup de parisiens
parce que maintenant je me suis aperçu
que les parisiens
souvent dans la petite couronne et la
grande couronne parce qu'il est plus
facile de circuler parce que il boxe se
garer et j'ai récupéré pas mal de
clientèle de paris mais effectivement
j'ai pas beaucoup de clients étrangers
donc j'en aurais je pense encore moi
cette année voilà et du côté de gésiers
monsieur malouda paris pareil on n'a pas
de clients nous c'est une toute petite
c1 c'est une toute petite bourgade donc
nous n'a pas tellement de touristes qui
viennent spécialement pour découvrir jus
dié donc les vins pour les vacances ça
m'inquiète pas plus que ça on va garder
notre rythme
comme tous les ans voilà ce qu'on fait
et vous jean daniel laval est ce que les
yvelinois sont amateurs de cinéma l'été
en général oui ça se passe plutôt bien
sauf l'an dernier je vous dis moi ce que
vides mais non non ça se passe plutôt
bien alors après on mène des actions
fontenay c'est une vieille capitaux
active donc avec la bibliothèque on met
des actions d'animation il ya vous savez
il n'ya pas de tour on part en vacances
la télé et nous fait croire que tout le
monde a pris d'assaut la côte d'azur et
la côte vendéenne mais enfin tout ma
part pas en vacances on a nous a trompés
beaucoup de gens qui sont là beaucoup de
gens mais je peux vous dire que la
mairie comme d'autres mairies des villes
a qu à côté je déforme que font peser
mais le travail beaucoup à ce que les
animateurs prennent en charge les
enfants qui sont beaucoup là il y en a
beaucoup qui sont sur place et je pense
que gaëtan et témoins il a beaucoup de
gens qui connaît qui travaillent l'été
et qui sont dans son restaurant les gens
lui dit ne serait-ce que midi sur la
région les banques les trucs et les
trucs immobilier travail en a que cinq
semaines de vacances dans l'année ça
beaucoup juillet-août il faut bien ça
fait huit semaines mais je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête sur ces mots on aura bien
compris que l'élan du 19 mai était
présent on verra pour la suisse que ça
donnera le cette société maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on se
redresse
prochaine merci or un nouveau moment de
discussion et d'ici là bien sûr prenez
soin de vous
[Musique]